[Musique]
et bédié l'eau et du bien précis non
c'est pas du brouillard et c'est bien
fait mais on se tire respira s'applique
la gorge au credo scheer ce sens mode
[Musique]
hu à tous à tous les niveaux il va faire
semblant d'être intoxiqué
[Musique]
[Rires]
et patrons regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave au moins il aurait quand
même eu un besoin d'un bon bol d'air
[Musique]
à credo chien va mieux à temps c'est pas
fini
[Musique]
cet incident ne va pas passer inaperçue
le soir même à la télévision et le
lendemain matin à la une tous les aurons
rolala mais c'est terrible c'est vrai il
ya de fumer dans cette usine il faut
absolument alerter l'opinion et
souplesse c'est un scandale
il n'y a pas de fumée sans le pdg
convoqué il faut faire quelque chose ça
ne peut plus durer comme ça alors tondre
les employés des usines sont convoqués
il faut faire quelque chose ça ne peut
plus durer comme ça
regardez patron j'ai une idée allons-y
ça marche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est propre c'est fini on peut y
aller
[Musique]
à
et voilà c'est beaucoup mieux le ciel
est bleu maintenant et on peut même
faire une ronde autour des cheminées
puisqu'il n'y a plus de fumée au revoir
ou à toi ton inertie
[Musique]
et